hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
endlich mal wieder einer neuen snapshot
vorstellungen und zwar von dem snapshot
13 w 09
ja es wird nicht sehr viele hinzugefügt
und zwar die einzigen sachen werde ich
euch gleich mal kurz zeigen ihr fragt
euch mit sicherheit hey was hatten der
rechts aufgebaut einige werden oder fast
alle wenn es wahrscheinlich schon kennen
in den letzten updates also 13 08 a 13
05 zum beispiel 13 01 oder es sind sehr
viele red dawn sachen dazugekommen die
habe ich aber alle nicht vorgestellt die
ganzen snapshots ganz einfach weil mir
das zu rot steinig war wenn ihr versteht
was ich meine
ich kenne ich halt nicht so doll aus mit
bridgestone und ich wette stand für das
1.5 update was anfang märz erscheinen
wird oder mitte märz oder irgendwie so
da werde ich mich dann um 1 formieren
wird dann ganz langes video dazu machen
euch versuchen alles näher zu bringen
und ihr euch hoffentlich das sind aber
wir wissen bin ich nicht so ganz der
profi in allen möglichen sachen das
gaming angeht deswegen habe ich euch
jetzt einfach aufgebaut also dass uns
ein paar features die 1.50 wirkt zum
beispiel hier starke platten oder
schwache platten sensoren im redstone
blocken trichter so ein doppelter
repeater den man hier noch so umstellen
kann das ist alles sehr geil der kunde
seine letzten fackel raus oder i'm never
quarz heißt es glaube ich unters messer
christiane z sie habe ich da schon
mittel informiert aber für 1.5 kommt
dann halt immer so ein richtig heftiges
video und was jetzt erstmal so
hauptsächlich dazu geführt wurde in 13
w01 billig euch jetzt einfach mal links
oben ein material links oben so da seht
ihr nun ein bild und zwar es unten eine
spinne darüber ein brennendes schwein
und darüber ein schwein oder darüber ein
brennendes skelett das ist ganz einfach
früher gab es ja diese diese wie sony
pictures reiter irgendwie sowas schießen
die kleine spenden unter 31 gillett und
das skelett quasi die spinne reitet das
war dann so ein doppelter kämpfer
irgendwie so dass gibt es nun allerdings
mit allen möglichen kombination das
heißt es kann sein dass ein krieg eine
spinne reitet oder das
schweinen skelett reiten oder irgendwie
sowas mo yan beschreibt das so mops can
your right stuff that right stuff that
last of the trade satz darf also es geht
immer so weiter so gut dass jetzt mal
das foto engadget gesehen ich habe es
versucht selbst zu spawnen dient
allerdings nicht einer spinne gespannt
die müsst ihr noch im forum watscheln
unter wasser deswegen ins wasser
geflohen war sehr witzig und dann hab
ich dann versucht einfach so eine spinne
drauf einfach so ein schwein
draufzusetzen scrat oder so das ging
einfach nicht zusammen zu drücken
zusammenzuschlagen das ging nicht
naja dann kommen wir zur zweiten sache
und zwar wenn spieler etwas reiten also
sei es ein schwein oder sei es zb ein
kart oder was gibt es sonst noch bot zum
beispiel und ich setze mich da jetzt zum
beispiel mal ganz einfach rein so jetzt
sitze ich da drin wenn ich mich jetzt
aus locke und dann wieder der reihen
geldern was damals so dass man jetzt
einfach daneben sorrent aber jetzt ist
es so dass ich da wirklich weiter drin
sitzt und us-markt aber wegen ein
bisschen rum ich hänge ja ganz schön da
ja in meinem kreislauf oder kreher
kopfschmerzen sondern hat es irgendwie
komisch verrückt naja gut so also man
man bleibt da drin wenn man sich aus
lockt sag ich mal
nun wenn man animierte blöcke hat zum
beispiel was essen animiert zum beispiel
der bieten blog wenn man die in einem
texture pack animiert sind also in einem
texture pack was ihr quasi hinzufügt
dass das eine animation definition also
eine art beschreibung oder eine nähere
zusammenfassung
das ist eine texture pack hersteller
wichtig und vorher war das als optional
ob man das macht mittlerweile ist es mit
diesem 13 vj 0 1 a ist es wirklich
verbindlich dass man das machen muss und
dann das letzte was gemacht wurde ist
dass die language files angeblich
gefixed wurden
also wenn ich hier zum beispiel einfach
mal was so ich die sprache kann ich
jetzt das wird alles ein bisschen besser
gemacht allerdings was ein bug ist hier
meine ganzen sachen werden falsch
angezeigt die warum nur das richtig
angezeigt
also das ist im bug den ich entdeckt
habe und das war es
es gibt sowieso ganz ganz ganz ganz
viele motto back bewegungen wie zum
beispiel corporate scorsese blog update
wide web osten nahm das und change it in
a love story nimmt ein entweder oder so
ganz ganz viele sachen die damals wohl
falsch waren aber jetzt gefixed wurden
also eigentlich ein sehr sehr recht
recht kleines update finde ich
allerdings dass du noch heftigere
monster auftreten können und dass man in
den sachen drin bleibt wenn man dann
einfach nicht mehr aus block finde ich
auf jeden fall sehr cool ich hoffe euch
hat es gefallen wenn ja dann bewertet
das bitte mit einem daumen nach oben das
wird mich auf jeden fall freuen und wird
mir zeigen ob ich auch so was gefällt
dass ich euch einfach nun in zukunft
alle infos näher bringen egal wie lange
das ist und war mir ständig die macht
kann man einfach meine augen zu allein
der sound macht mich schon schwindelig
naja freunde dann würde ich sagen
schreib mir die kommentare was ihr euch
für das nächste update erhofft
beziehungsweise was ihr schon alles über
die 1.5 ist und würde ich sagen sehen
uns beim nächsten mal tschüss